[Music]
How are you?
Happy
[Music]
Christ.
Perfect.
[Music]
Welcome. Welcome everyone. My name is
Janine. My pronouns are she and her.
We're so glad to see you all here today.
Wanted to let you know that you are not
only welcome here, but you are
celebrated here, whether you are in
person or you online. Thank you so much.
All right. If you're interested in
becoming a member at the table or simply
learning more about who we are as a
community and how you might want to get
involved,
then please sign up for the welcome to
the table class next Sunday, August
24th, 3 to 4:30 p.m. S scan the code
when it comes up.
All right. Some of us get a little
anxious being in a church setting, maybe
part of a disability community or just
feeling fidgety today. And if you feel
that way, over by the door is an
accessibility bucket. There are
noiseancelling headphones, fidgets,
coloring sheets. We just ask that you
return them when you finish with them at
the end of the service.
These candles that I've lit is a sign of
the presence of Christ among us, fully
divine and fully human.
Now, let's just take a moment to relax,
take a deep breath.
We are going to exit the kingdom of
noise and hurry and productivity.
We're going to enter the kingdom of
silence and stillness and simplicity.
A sacred space,
a place for prayer,
for worship, for adoration,
a place to behold Christ, the revelation
of God, heartbeat of creation.
Allow the unforced rhythms of grace to
find you.
to mend your heart
and may we all come home.
>> Thanks, John. If you guys want to stand
with us, we're going to get started with
worship. We're so glad y'all are here.
And um tonight we're just leaning into
um just a space where Christ has invited
us to come as we are. Um, and I love
sometimes I do love smaller sets where
it's just one instrument. There's just
something about like stripping some of
the extra away that kind of exposes us
in a way. Even tonight as we rehearsing,
I was feeling more vulnerable than I
normally do. Like, oh my goodness, it's
so we're just we're just so out there.
But I've been reading this book that
actually Jesse Watts gave to me for
Christmas. It's called um Why Worship
Matters. And there was a section in it
that was talking about um how Christ has
called us to purity. And I know that
that word has its own kind of
attachments. Um if you grew up in the
church, if you're around my age, it has
a lot of baggage sometimes for certain
people. But it was um it was saying that
when we're coming before God in worship,
when we're opening up this space as a
congregation to gather together to sing
these songs, if we're not doing it from
a place of purity, honesty,
if we if you want to replace that word,
from a place of honesty, from realness,
where there's not extra attachments,
where there's not hiding behind or
masking things, but you're coming with a
pure heart, honest before God. That's
where we meet him and his spirit is real
and alive in us. So, let's lean in that
together. Um, and I just encourage you
guys to sing along if you know the
words. And if you don't, if you want to
just take them in, you're welcome to do
that. This is a space for each one of us
to experience him and his spirit as it
comes.
Could
we bring you the word of our hands
now? Lay it down. Lay it at your feet.
What we done, what we built, what we
broken,
lay it down
at your feet.
You hold
it
all,
Jesus. You hold
it all.
Heart, spirit hands, waking bodies.
Lay it down. Bring it at your feet.
What we've used, what we've lost, what
we've wasted.
Lay it down and lay it at your feet.
You hold
it
all,
Jesus. You hold
it
all.
You hold it
all,
Jesus. You hold
it.
Oh,
all our dreams, all our plans, our
vision,
lay it down, lay it at your feet.
Even if nothing comes to fruition,
lay it down. Lay it at your feet.
Lay it down. Lay it on at your feet.
All right, our kiddos are dismissed to
go to their classes. And if you're new
here, our teachers are going to meet you
guys right over by those brown doors and
they'll take you to your classes. Um,
thank you so much, Eve and Maitlin and
Resa, Maggie. Um, I think August is back
in the nursery tonight. We appreciate
you guys so much for loving on them.
And we're going to transition into
prayers of the people.
[Music]
So, this is a tradition that was passed
out throughout Christian history. And uh
we have words up on the screen. The
words in red we can all say aloud
together. Um, and then in the middle of
the prayer, we will pause for a time
where you can lift up what you're
bringing into this space tonight. So,
feel free to speak it out loud. Whether
it's a a person that's on your heart or
a situation, u maybe something going on
globally, you can share that out loud
and then um we'll continue on with the
prayer.
Jesus, for this city of Sax, Texas, and
for every city and community and all who
live in them, we pray to you for the
good earth you have given us, and the
wisdom and the will to conserve it. We
pray to you for the old and the sick,
for the widow and orphan, for the
injured and suffering. We pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed, the
unemployed and destitute, for prisoners
and captives, and all who remember and
care for them. We pray to you for the
vulnerable, the marginalized, and those
unjustly targeted for their gender,
sexuality, race, or other perceived
difference. We pray to you for those
experiencing loss, loneliness, and
disconnection. And for those struggling
with mental and emotional health, we
pray to you, Lord. We know that you love
us and that you hear us. So we lift
these names and situations up to you.
[Music]
For the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept. in our hearts. We pray to you
that they may have life and light,
healing and hope, peace, and a deep
sense of your presence.
Amen.
[Music]
Here
is where I lay it down. Every burden,
every cry. This is my surrender.
This is my surrender.
Here is where I lay down every lie and
devil.
This is my surrender.
And I will make room for you
to do whatever you want to
to do whatever you want to.
And I will make room for you
[Music]
to do whatever you want to.
You can do whatever you want to.
Here is where I lay head down. Every
burden, every crowd. This is my
surrender.
This is my surrender.
Here is where I lay head down. every lie
and every death. This is my surrender.
This is my surrender.
I will make room for you
to do whatever you want to
to do whatever you want to.
And I will make room for you
to do whatever you want to
to do whatever you want to.
[Music]
[Applause]
So shake up the ground for my tradition.
Break down the walls of all my religion.
Your way is better.
Shake up the ground. Don't call my
tradition. Break down the walls. All my
religion. Your way is better.
Your way is better.
Shake up the ground for my tradition.
Break down the walls for my revision.
Your way is better.
And I will make room for you
to do whatever you want to,
to do whatever you want to.
And I will make room for you
[Music]
to do whatever you want to.
Here is where I lay it down. You are all
I'm chasing now. This is my surrender.
This is my surrender.
Here is where I lay it down. You are all
I'm chasing now. This is my surrender.
This is my surrender.
[Music]
I'm caught up in your praisees
and I just want to sit here at your
feet.
I'm caught up in this holy
moment
and I never want to leave.
No, I'm not here for blessing.
Jesus, you don't owe me anything.
[Music]
>> More than anything
that you can do,
I just want you.
I'm sorry
when I've just gone through the motions.
when I just sang another song. Take me
back to where we started.
I open up my heart
to you.
I'm sorry
when I've come with my agenda.
when I forgot that you're enough. Take
me back to where we started.
I open up my heart
to you.
I'm caught up in your presence
and I just want to sit here at your
feet.
I'm caught up in this holy
moment
and I never want to leave.
No, I'm not here for blessing.
Jesus, you don't owe me anything.
more than anything
that you can do.
I just want you.
I'm
sorry
when I've just gone through the motions.
I'm sorry.
When you just sing another song to take
me back to where we started,
I open up my heart
to you.
And I'm sorry
when I've come with my agenda.
I'm sorry
when I forgot that you're enough.
Take me back to where every time.
I open up my heart
to you.
[Music]
And I just want you.
Nothing else.
[Music]
Nothing else will do.
I just want you.
Nothing else.
[Music]
Nothing else will do.
I just want you
and nothing else.
Nothing else.
Nothing else will do.
I just want you
and nothing else.
And nothing else. Jesus,
nothing else will do.
[Music]
Oh,
wo wo wo.
[Music]
I'm caught up in your presence.
And I just wanna sit here at your feet.
I'm caught up in this holy
moment
and I never want to leave.
[Music]
Jesus, would you remind us of who we are
when all the extra
falls away?
[Music]
Would you remind us of the beautiful
creation that you began long before we
were aware?
the good work that you started when you
knit us together.
[Music]
Spirit of God, would you come and fill
up our hearts in places that are weary,
that are angry,
that are confused?
Would you bring your balm of peace
and calm?
Would you bring your clarity and your
truth and speak to our hearts
as our creator who knows us better than
we know ourselves?
[Music]
Jesus, would you remind us of the things
that really matter?
[Music]
Would the fruit of your spirit root
itself in our lives?
Would
love
be the thing that leads us,
guides us,
calls us forward.
[Music]
Thank you for who you are and the way
that you love us.
May we experience more and more of it
tonight as we're together, as we sing,
as we listen, as we open our hearts in
Jesus name. Amen.
Thank you guys for worshiping with us.
If you would turn to the people on the
sides of you and say, "The peace of
Christ be with you.
[Music]
Well, grace and peace.
My name is Brett and uh I'm really glad
to to be here with you all to welcome
you into this space. And as always, that
includes joining us online. You're not
forgotten.
So glad y'all could be with us in this
way. And uh and especially anyone here
tonight who is new. I know what a just
it can be just a scary thing. It can be
difficult coming through those double
doors for the first time and uh you know
just into a space like this and and
especially considering you know past
church uh history to put it gently
sometimes church trauma and uh it can it
can just be a lot. So um all that to say
we're really really glad that you're
that you're here tonight. So um oh and I
also wanted to give a a quick shout out
to all of our I know we're kind of back
into the school rhythm. So, we have like
a number of teachers and administrators
and uh if that's you, if you're in that
kind of position, would you go ahead and
stand so we can give you I know we got
at least one back here. We got here.
Give them a hand.
[Applause]
You count you count. That's that's the
work of the Lord
>> there in those schools.
So, yeah, we're really um we're grateful
for you all. Um so the title of well I
should have mentioned we're kicking off
a new series um titled Cultivating Calm
Staying Centered in difficult times and
uh Charles Dickens he began his famous
novel A Tale of Two Cities with the uh
the opening sentence was it was the best
of times it was the worst of times and
that's a good little summary of kind of
almost every moment in a way you know
it's like there's so I mean in essence
like there's a lot to be grateful for
you know I was thinking back like in my
own kind of life and comparing it to
previous generations. And I I wouldn't
trade places with like my grandparents
or my great-grandparents. You know, it's
like no, there's a lot to be grateful
for. I want my running water and, you
know, my air conditioning in Texas. Uh
there's, you know, there's there's a lot
to be grateful for. Um and yet at the
same time, uh there's plenty that can
be, you know, to put it mildly, just a
bit much, right? There's there's a lot
that can kind of be stressing us out to
kind of to the max. I spent a good
portion of my July break. Uh many of you
know I was out in in that month and I
spent a good portion of it researching
all the breakthroughs in artificial
intelligence and where all that's going.
And I'm not going to lie, that will
stress you out. Like don't do it. Just
just don't worry about it'll be fine.
It's going to be fine. You know, um it
could just it just felt like a lot, you
know. It was sort of all the potential
change. It's like the the brain is kind
of predictive system and my brain just
got in this mode of like trying to
predict like well where is it going and
what are the implications of that and
you know it's just oh my gosh like this
is too too much and but it's not just
you know AI like we've got big issues we
got political issues you know wars in
the world I'm thinking Ukraine uh
Palestinian catastrophe with Israel uh
and uh well and even kind of more in a
local kind of pressing way here in the
United States, we've got all of the
terrible just scapegoating of the LGBTQ
community. I really think that's just
what it is. Like it's it's a I mean like
for example like trans people are like
what like 1% of the population, you
know, but oh but that's the problem in
America, you know, like that's the thing
we really need to obsess. Like what?
It's just ridiculous. Like I I really um
yeah I I I think the and we feel it here
in our community and um and even the way
it's playing out I' I've heard from a
number of we were just talking about the
teachers administrators and how that's
playing out in like school districts
like WY. Um I'm not sure how it's
playing out in in Garland ISD but uh
there's you know all the new laws and
things around kids names. It's, you
know, it's uh it's just it's kind of
taking what was a safe place for people,
you know, and and turning it into not
that. So, we've got, you know, all of
that. And then you kind of add, you
know, the social political to just, you
know, everyday life stuff, you know what
I mean? like just the stresses of family
life and some of you are raising
children and uh I know we have a number
of folks going through job loss and like
just kind of you start adding you know
all that swirling around and at some
point we're just like stressing you know
and we I don't know if you're like me
you find yourself in a place of saying
like oh Jesus like please like help me
reenter
uh find a certain calm a peace you you
know, in the midst of of the storm. And
the storm, it looks a little different,
you know, for each of us, but in many
ways, most weeks, you know, at some
point, we're hitting the storm. Most
months, most seasons of life, there's
storms that we're weathering. So, that's
kind of what we're getting into in this
series is basically asking like, well,
how do we kind of cultivate a calm? Um,
that that can build over time. time, you
know, I don't think of the series as
like a one shot, you know, like, oh,
you'll always have the peace of Christ
forever after the series, you know, but
but more like how can we grow into this
over weeks and months and years to build
a kind of um deeprooted calm in in God.
So, with that in mind, uh the title of
my message for uh the sermon today is
overcoming fear. Overcoming fear. Our
scripture is Isaiah chapter 41 verse 10.
This is the the Lord speaking through
the prophet Isaiah says, "So do not fear
for I am with you.
Do not be dismayed for I am your God. I
will strengthen you and help you. I will
uphold you with my righteous right
hand."
You know, fear fear is a tricky one.
Like on the one hand, fear it's a it's a
perfectly natural process, right? Right.
I don't I don't want to kind of like
demonize it in this uh this sermon. It's
not like bad or evil. I mean, in many
ways, it's just it's there to protect
us, you know, like we had a kind of
funny moment uh only because we avoided
the catastrophe. My brother-in-law and I
were working on our pool pump over July
and we were out there for like an hour
just trying to install this new thing,
you know, and neither of us are very
handy, honestly. So, it probably took us
like twice as long. We're just like out
there. So, and all of a sudden, he turns
and he's like, "Oh my gosh, dude, did
you see this?" I'm like, "What?" And
there's a it was a giant hornets's nest
just right there that was kind of behind
tug and we just been working, you know,
just right around it like for like an
hour just like and we saw it and we're
like, you know, I had that fear like the
chills kind of run through me like, "Oh,
that could have been bad." You know? So
that's like normal, you know what I
mean? That that's that's good. It's good
that I've I've run into hornets before,
didn't go well,
and my brain tells me avoid that, you
know? So, this is like, right, this is
this is good. Uh, it's there to protect
us. And yet, at the exact same time,
fear, it's it's it's way beyond that.
Like, it is it's powerful beyond belief.
like it it strikes us
so quickly
which again in that kind of moment of
the hornness is very helpful for that to
be instinct and you kind of back away
and you know you don't need to sit there
like now what is that I think I
recognize you know like it needs to be
quick it need but but that's also the
danger of fear because it strikes us so
quickly it just activates our nervous
system that uh it hits us and and kind
of can take us even into irrational you
know crazy decisions that we like really
regret later and Of course, the way this
can play out like even in society, uh,
clever politicians in leaders end up
like using that, right? Kind of
manipulating us, playing fear like a
fiddle that kind of gets us going and
they can use it to manipulate.
But the problem isn't just kind of out
there like leaders or something. It's
it's really even just us like I think of
our kind of history, you know, our our
ancestors.
uh how did they survive? You know, it
was I mean, in essence, the reason they
were able to pass on their genes to you
is because they made it, they were
anxious and afraid, right? All the
chilled ones, all the laid-back ones are
kind of like, ah, nothing to worry about
and well, less likely to to bring about
you. You know what I mean? And and so
like I think this even evolutionary
history kind of selects for this where
so today here we are with pantries full
of food
you know with people most of us have
like community and some people who love
us we don't have like war on our very
doorstep
you know and yet
we're kind of activated you know what I
mean we're kind of freaked out or at the
very least there's a kind of unease you
know it can kind of manifest as anxiety
or a more kind of acute chronic um fear
that we just it's it's like there it's
just with us and we're kind of on full
alert. The the famous biologist Edward O
Wilson summed it up really nicely. He
said, "The real problem of humanity is
the following. We have paleolithic
emotions, medieval institutions, and
godlike technology."
That that's a word right there.
And of course in this series I'm kind of
focusing on those paleolithic
emotions right those primal like way
back this fear stuff right goes very
very deep into us as human beings as as
a species those fear pathways are strong
and because of that
fear is dangerous right it can it can
blind us it can hijack us it can take us
where we in our ser moments actually do
not want to go.
I remember like this is probably a
decade ago. I was there in the kitchen.
I was unloading the dishwasher. One of
my kiddos was there and this is I think
it was Dax who's now like 13. So he
would have been like threeish or so. And
we're unloading the dishwasher or I am
and he's kind of helping, you know, in
like the three-year-old way sort of like
here's a plate, you know, whatever. And
I turn. I was putting something away in
the cupboard. I turn, you know, I'm
doing it. I come back and there he is by
the dishwasher with a butcher knife.
And y'all, like I just lose it. Like it
was kind of weird how it came out.
Honestly, it came out as fury at him.
You know what I mean? I was just like,
D, like what are you doing? You know,
I'm just put that down. He's like, you
know, just and I I realized honestly he
could have like dropped it on his foot
or something crazy. Like this was not
how I needed to go about it, you know,
and he'd be like, "Oh, buddy. Okay,
here. Get back to daddy." Like that
would have been a sane, calm thing to
do, you know. But that's not at all how
it came out. Uh I mean, sometimes anger
is just anger at an injustice or, you
know, something. But sometimes anger,
what's underneath that anger? You know,
it's fear. It's anxiety. Like actually,
I wasn't like angry at him. you know, I
I was super afraid. Poor him. It's cuz I
loved him so much. That's why I'm
screaming at you, son. You know, it's I
feel love. Can you feel? You know, um
and and this is this is where
uh fear gets us, you know. It's it's the
way it kind of comes out sideways and
all these and we like regret it. You
know, we're just, oh my gosh, I just why
is this eating me uh alive?
And
of course, we all have those kind of
explosive moments, but really what I
want to zero in on tonight is is not so
much the momentary kind of acute, you
know, like, ah, my kid was holding a
butcher knife and I yelled, you know,
okay. Um, I'm thinking more of like the
the kind of the way sometimes a
momentary fear becomes kind of chronic,
you know, a kind of perpetual
and it's probably not level 10, you
know, it's like a level three or four
and then it spikes occasionally, you
know, maybe up to a 10, but then it's
down. It's that's the that's the fear
that I think in many ways like it's kind
of eating away at us. You know it it can
happen when one person in our life
abandons us. M maybe it was when we were
five, maybe 15, maybe even 35, whatever.
What one person abandons us and now what
happens? We live with this chronic kind
of lowline perpetual fear that everyone
will abandon me. I'll I'll be alone and
that's so dangerous. And now all of a
sudden I'm like living every day with
this kind of level three chronic fear.
We fail once and now what happens? We're
like we almost had you ever had those
moments where if any perfectionists in
the room where you're just like I swear
and I swear to myself when I failed I
swore I would never fail again. You know
I would that would never happen to me
again. I'm going to be perfect. I see I
love that with the uh kids in grades. I
was kind of that kid going through some
of you were like, "Dude, I was chill."
My kids shock me. I have kids that they
don't care about grades. I can't believe
that. I'm like, "What kind of a human is
this? That's not like anxious and
wanting to please the teacher and be an
A+ and you know what I mean? They're
just like, eh, what does it matter?" You
know, I'm like, "Oh my god, that was not
me." You know, I was just like, "I need
to what if I get a B minus? What does
that say about me?" I was like, "Oh my
god." I look back on that just like it's
insane.
You know, but this is this is what fear
does to us. It just gets its like talons
in. You know what I mean? It just won't
let us go. One dog bites us and now
we're scared of all dogs forever.
Just fear, fear, fear, you know, just
haunts us. I think haunt's the right
word. Modern neuroscience has shown us
that within our brains the the fear
system which is like the amydala and the
hypothalamus and the hippocampus uh it's
also it's a memory system and and you
can see where kind of as we've been
alluding to this is both genius and
deeply unhelpful right it's genius as in
that as we talked about it helps protect
us I recognize that hornets's nest my
brain's seen that before you know and
that's the good part of it protects us
it's unhelpful though in that that same
memory system is like replaying these
danger danger danger and and I think in
a lot of ways society plays on this
right you we've all heard the way 24/7
news you know it's like we even say like
well why don't they just play the good
news why you know why isn't that well
because no one watches it you know it's
the bad news that keeps us glued
you know what I mean because that it's
it's priming something it's touching
something in us and it keeps us coming
back. I've got to stay in the loop. I've
got to know. It's it's it's danger
danger danger unless I you know what I
mean? And of course, social media takes
that and like levels it up to level 10
because now I have it in my pocket all
day and I just keep scrolling, right?
It's it's playing with us. It's it's
messing with us. I I wonder uh or I
should say wonder. I know like this is
one reason um I think addiction is like
very prevalent in our society and it's
because you know like substance abuse or
or whatever we tend to abuse you know we
all kind of have our addiction of choice
um it's the way that it's it's not so
much a problem it's a solution to a
problem you know what I mean like in a
deeper level it is a problem but you
know what I mean like it's a it's the
solution it's oh when I take that in
when I have that substance when I have
finally What
peace?
Of course, the danger is it's addictive,
you know. So then I need more and you
know, we all know how that that plays
out. But but at at least for a while, it
all just kind of fades, you know. So the
question for us tonight is what's the
more healthy path to deal with it? you
know, not the loop of addiction, and we
all know where that can take us to dark
places and such, but what's a more
healthy um lifegiving way to actually
deal with our fear um and and how do we
kind of welcome God into the midst of
it? So, what I want to do is give you
kind of three steps tonight. I don't
always preach threepoint sermons. We got
a classic tonight. Classic three points.
So, uh three steps. And step number one
is this. I need awareness of my fear.
Now, this may seem obvious, but it's
amazing how kind of as I was naming like
I think we're driven by fear much more
so than we realize.
So, that's where we step one is
awareness. Start tuning in. What is it?
What's the fear that's driving you? And
once you start growing in this
awareness, I'll just tell you like at
least speaking from my own experience,
you will be shocked
at because there's like the three things
or whatever that you know, oh yeah, I'm
afraid of that and that and that. But as
you go start going through your day
tuning in, all of a sudden you're like,
oh my gosh, fear, fear, fear, fear,
fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear,
fear, fear, fear, fear. You're like, oh
Lord. like it is driving it is in many
ways it's in the driver's seat of our
life I think at at more profound levels
than we um than we even realize. One way
to think of it is almost anytime we have
emotional upset, you know, we've all had
those moments of we're flying like me
yelling at my child with the butcher
knot, you know, or whatever, we're just
kind of a we lose it. What's under you
always have to ask you what's underneath
that? What's going on there? Usually,
not everything I think comes back to
this, but usually it's like one of two
things. Feeling unloved, feeling unsafe.
Like most of the, you know, oh, feeling
unloved, feeling unsafe. Like that's so
of course tonight we're talking about
that it's the unsafe piece but this is
like huge for us. One of my my own kind
of fear tells I struggle with anxiety so
is my uh throat and I
I try to keep it as quiet as I can so
that I don't annoy people.
But it's kind of like when I start
getting anxious, that's my kind of
and I noticed I've mentioned earlier
when I was like a few times I was
reading or listening to podcast and I'm
hearing about all the artificial
intelligence stuff and I'm just I c I
caught myself like literally like
oh my god and but it was a it was a good
awareness moment for me you know what I
mean to know like oh this is impacting
me like probably time to close the book
or turn off the pod or take a I need a
break here. My nervousness, I'm getting
all, you know, worked up. But the point
is, we need, we got to start here,
right? We got to start with awareness to
tune into what are the things, what's
the fear that's driving you at levels
that right now you aren't consciously
aware of. Uh because there is a few
things you're aware of, but it's the
it's the things you aren't aware of
that's making you miserable. You just
don't know it yet. You know what I mean?
So this is uh where we have to start.
Step one. So first we need some
awareness. Second step is I I need to
renarrate my fear.
Rearrate like this is how we begin to
break free. So one way to understand
fear is as this kind of um this chronic
narrative. This is part of what you
become aware of is there's this nar this
story in your head that's playing out
about the fear. You know what I mean?
And it's and it's looping in your mind.
So what you have to do is first
awareness. Oh that story there it's
going. It's playing out again that
danger danger danger danger and like up
to your rational levels you know. Okay
it's happening. And then what do you do?
You've got to bring in a new story, a
new narrative. Because I think this kind
of brings us back to Isaiah 41:10
because I think we're often telling
ourselves very humiliating,
disempowering,
dreadfilled
stories
and it's eating us alive. But the power
of scripture and the power of Christ is
that we now have the resources to do
what? To tell a new story.
And many of us here tonight like
desperately need a new story.
Do not fear for I am with you. Do not be
dismayed for I am your God. What's that
getting at? I mean it's saying you are
not alone.
That that experience you went through
and you thought to yourself like I am I
am all alone. Like no one is there for
me. I cannot count on anyone at all.
No. No. The Lord is with you.
Christ is with you. God is the God who
sees you. And that's part of the new
narrative that we need, right? I'm not
alone. I'm not cut off. No, God is with
me. God does see me. The Lord was with
me then when I went through that awful
experience that I'm so freaked out
about. Repeating the Lord was with me
then, and the Lord is with me now.
Though I walk through the valley of the
shadow of death, I will fear no evil.
Isaiah continues, "I will strengthen you
and help you. I will uphold you with my
righteous right hand.
See, we're often telling ourselves
very uh disempowering
stories.
That might be the worst story to tell
ourselves. Like, I mean, it's one thing
to be kind of freak ourselves out about
things, but to literally kind of drain
us of any sense of like with God, I can
do it. With God, I can get through. You
know what I to like lose that is like
that's a that's a dark place to be,
right? We tell ourselves these stories
of helplessness. I am so weak. I'm so
defenseless. No one can protect me. I'll
never be safe again.
See, this is where we need a new story.
Christ is even now strengthening you.
Christ is even now helping you. The
thief came to steal, kill, and destroy.
But Christ has come to give you life and
life to the full.
The Lord upholds me with his right hand.
In scripture, the uh the right hand is a
picture of authority, right? Whoever sat
at the right hand of the king had the
authority of the king. And so this is
saying like you as a child of the living
God, you have the power, you have the
authority of the king. And so you too as
a child of living God, you like you have
a new story to tell, right? And so in
essence, what do we need to do? We need
to get into a safe place. And that's
key, by the way, if you're in like
danger, like get out of danger and then
start to tell a new story. This of
course is uh precisely what happens in
therapy, right? Like this is like
classic if you have trauma work to work
through. What do they do? It's like they
walk you back through the situations now
in a safe place. But now we're telling a
new story to our brain, right? Actually,
it's okay. Actually, people do love me.
The truth is such a you know what I
mean? There there's a new and you're
you're renarrating the experience. So
that can happen in a clinical setting.
But really the point is really to take
this though into like daily life, you
know. So that leads us into the uh the
third and final step. I need to persist
in the new story until the fear
subsides.
Like I mentioned earlier, I wish I could
say like, boy, if you will renarrate,
then you'll be healed. You know, voila,
you do this one time and it's like
you're not afraid of anything anymore.
Uh but of course, unless it's a very
weak fear, that's just not the case.
It's like what has to happen is you got
to rewire that brain. You know what I
mean? And you when the thing comes up,
awareness comes up. You realize, oh, and
then you renarrate and over time you
start to heal and as you tell that that
new new story at the uh at the beginning
of the year, we had in our family two um
I mean I guess in a way it's sort of one
thing. It was like just financial
stress. It kind of came through two
avenues. One avenue was people warned me
of this. Uh we're getting kids in the
teen years now and they I mean they've
been warning me for a decade like those
teen years are expensive. That's what
they're like it's expensive, you know.
So we added or added my daughter who
turned 16 to insurance.
Oh my gosh.
Um you got little ones now. Just save
up. You know what I mean? Just start the
savings account now. that hits and then
just other you know and then they're
also just eating more you know it went
from we have three kids so we went from
like two adults three kids to like two
adults well now is it like four and a
half adults you know what I mean like
it's just the bills just keep going up
so it was we had that kind of happening
and then I don't know if some of y'all
have experienced this but our home
insurance
uh was basically trying to intentionally
price us out of the market so they
increased our rates by 400%
400%
and We wanted to switch, but we had an
open claim back from not this May, but
the previous May. Remember the big storm
that came through here in kind of Saxy
Wy all our trees like blew down. Our
roof got messed up, but they didn't want
to cover the So, we've been in this
dispute. So, we couldn't switch or we
could, but we'd have to drop the claim,
but we really needed to proceed with the
claim. So, it's been this terrible like
we were just in this kind of catch 22,
you know, where you need to change, but
you can't. And so, I'm in charge of the
finances in our home. So every like
month, you know, I go there to like
review and do the thing and like, well,
I just found this fear story going. I
mean, it was pretty subtle and nuanced.
Like it was something like panic, panic,
panic, your your finances are a disaster
shambles, you know? It was like which I
realized like as I actually looked at it
like was that true? No. Like it was
okay. It was just tight. You know what I
mean? It was just tight. But the story
in my head was just like, "Oh my gosh,
this is a disaster." Like so stressful.
But what happened was, of course, I had
a chance to work on this like every
month. So as I started to tune in to
like, okay, this is like I'm getting
worked up here, you know, I was like in
a bad mood every month when I have to do
the financial, you know, review. And uh
I I actually started to memorize Isaiah
41:10 was part of my process. Like don't
fear, I'm with you. Don't be dismayed.
I'm your God. I'll strengthen you. I'll
help you. uphold you with my righteous
right hand doing finances and just like
do not fear I'm with is this fine you
know and uh and it really did it became
a part of my kind of re you know
narrating process and by the way that
whole insurance situation got wrapped up
in July hallelujah so we're like new new
company we're like you're fired you know
we're actually on the phone with the
person the claims agent my wife was and
she said like oh is there any way we can
keep you my wife's like actually no you
increased your rates by 400 but she's
like oh let me look at it oh my
literally like the insurance agent said
like, "Oh, oh, no, oh, yeah. No, I
understand why you're leaving." You
know, it's like, "Yeah." Uh, but but
this is what we can do, right? It's it's
as we bring this awareness and this
renarration,
um, we start to catch oursel in the
midst of our fear and we start to
realize like, oh, it's happening right
now. It's happening again. I mean, and
that's a gift, right? when you can
actually start to catch yourself in the
moment, not just two days later when
you're like, "Yeah, that was my bad."
You know what I mean? Or a week like,
"Okay, actually, I was just afraid." You
know, it's much better to catch yourself
in the moment and realize, "Oh, no. Oh,
here we are. Okay, don't fear. I'm with
you. Don't be dismayed. I'm your God.
I'll strengthen you. I'll help you. I'll
uphold you with my righteous right
hand." And you can see where this
becomes a very powerful practice. So, to
close out, fear. Yeah, it's dangerous
for sure. It can blind us. It can hijack
us. Can, as we said, take us where we in
our s moments don't want to go. But you
know what? Fear can also be one of our
greatest teachers.
If only we have the wisdom to to be
aware, to renarrate, and then to persist
and move forward. In the name of the
father, the son, and the holy spirit.
Amen.
So on the uh
on the night that Jesus was betrayed, he
had one final meal with his disciples.
And at that meal, he held up a loaf of
bread and he broke it. And he said,
"Take it. Eat. This is my body. It's
broken for you." And he held up a cup of
wine. He said, "Take it. Drink. This is
my blood. It's shed for you. Whenever
you eat this bread, whenever you drink
this cup, remember me." And so this
becomes a very grounding practice for
many of us to connect again with Christ,
the very source of our peace, of our
calm, to know that we're safe in the
Lord's arms. So the way we'll
participate in communion tonight is
we'll just kind of go rowby row. We'll
start here at the front and just work
our way back. We'll form one line right
here in uh in the middle. And you should
know we practice an open table. So, uh,
everyone here is welcome to participate
regardless of your like exact, you know,
theology or or whatever. If you want to
connect with the risen Christ, then
you're you're welcome to do that. You
should know that the red is wine, the
white is grape juice. And, uh, finally,
you can just partake whenever and
however you'd like. Some folks like to
take it right away and return to their
seats. Some folks like to come forward
and kneel here. Uh, however you want to
to do it. No one will like lead you
through, you know, the exact moment of
taking the elements. You can just do
that on your on your own. So this is the
table
not of the church
but of the Lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more. So come you who have much faith
and you who have little you who have
been here often and you who have not
been here long. You who have tried to
follow and you who feel like you failed.
Come.
Come because it's the Lord Jesus himself
who invites you and it's his will that
those who want to meet him should meet
him here. Come to the table.
[Music]
As you finish your communion, you're
welcome to stand with us and sing this
last song. Um,
I just wanted to share really quickly.
There's a verse that says, "Perfect love
drives out fear."
And, um, I repeat that to myself
sometimes when I'm struggling with fear.
It's the only perfect love I've ever
experienced is this love of Christ that
stayed with me through it all in the
good and the bad from the beginning. And
let that be the answer. Let that be the
solution for the moments where we're
drowning, where we're afraid, where it's
creeping in. And so as we sing these
words tonight, let's carry them with us
into our week.
that our fear does not stand up against
his love.
When darkness tries to roll over my
bones,
Sorrow comes to steal the joy I
brokenness and pain are all I know
I won't be sh
I won't be shen
with you
doesn't stand a chance when I stand in
your love my fear
your love. My fear doesn't stand a
chance when I stand in your love.
>> Shame no longer has a place to hide.
And I am not a captive to the past.
I'm not afraid to leave my past behind.
I won't be shen.
My fear doesn't stand a chance when I
stand in your love. My fear doesn't
stand a chance when I'm standing your
love. My fear doesn't stand a chance
when I'm standing your love.
Because there's power that can break off
every chain.
And there's power that can empty out the
grave.
There's resurrection
power that can save.
There's power in your name. There's
power in your name.
And my fear it doesn't stand a chance
without standing your love. My fear it
doesn't stand a chance when not standing
your love. My fear it doesn't stand a
chance when not standing your love.
[Applause]
My fear doesn't stand a chance without
standing your love. My fear it doesn't
stand a chance without standing your
love. My fear doesn't stand a chance
without standing your love.
Standing your way.
[Music]
Well, this certainly
uh certainly reminds me of a quote, and
I'm going to give it to y'all. Love is
the way in, love is the way out, and
love is the way through.
All right, thank you so much for joining
us this evening. If you're new, we would
love to have you fill out a card at the
table on your way out or just scan the
QR code and fill out an online visitors
form.
Uh we have meetups, so we can all use a
little bit of relational support and
spiritual connection. And the way that
we do that here at the table is via the
meetup groups. So, if you're not part of
a meetup, you can scan the code and see
if there's a group that might fit you.
Uh, generosity is a key aspect of a life
of adoration and worship. And so, if the
table is your church home and you want
to uh give financially, you can go to
the tabletx.org
or scan the code.
All right. Now,
let me send you into the week with this
blessing. And you can hold your hands
out in a posture of receiving or you can
just open your hearts up to these words.
You are a child of God.
You You are a child of God. And this is
true on your best day and it's true on
your worst day. So as you go into your
week ahead with its yet to be determined
highs and lows and everything in
between, go filled with the assurance
that you are loved, that you are worthy,
and you are accepted just as you are.
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend the same gifts of
grace and unconditional love to everyone
that you come in contact with. Be
blessed and we'll see you next Sunday.
There's power that can break off every
chain.
There's power that can empty up the
grave.
There's resurrection
power that can save.
There's power in your name. Power in
your name.
My